bonjour merci d'être avec nous sur
installer france au-delà du contexte
sanitaire qu'est ce qui vous a motivé à
rédiger cette tribune basse et la
situation épidémiologique actuellement
qui nous a un tout petit peu inquiète et
pourquoi pas ce que l'on observe une
augmentation régulière et constante du
nombre de nouvelles contaminations et
désormais on observe en parallèle une
augmentation des admissions à l'hôpital
est en réanimation de patients
présentant des formes plus grave de kobe
de 19
donc nous sommes encore très loin de la
situation de mars avril 2020 et c'est à
ce moment qu'il faut prendre toutes les
mesures pour éviter d'en arriver une
situation comparable et donc
effectivement aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que le lieu principal où se font
les contaminations et bien c'est les les
lieux de réunions familiales au sens
élargi du terme où des rassemblements
amicaux ou des soirées privées et donc
c'est dans ces lieux qu'il faut faire un
effort et appliquer les mesures
barrières que l'on connaît vous vous
adressez dans cette tribune directement
aux français la démarche est plutôt rare
et vous avez le sentiment que le
gouvernement n'en fait pas assez
non je crois que le gouvernement on va
dire fait ce qui est nécessaire c'est à
dire effectivement le premier ministre a
donné les grandes lignes de la stratégie
a rappelé les mesures de prévention et
la nécessité de les appliquer le but
évidemment c'est de responsabiliser et
de mobiliser les citoyens car nous
devons vivre avec le virus et modifier
nos comportements sur une durée
prolongée par la suite évidemment
territoire par territoire il faut une
approche plus ciblée en fonction
évidemment de la situation
épidémiologique cette épidémie a pour
caractéristique de dépendre beaucoup du
département on a des départements où la
situation est 20 fois plus sérieuse que
dans d'autres et donc évidemment on
je comprendrais pas que des mesures à
l'échelle nationale stricte puisse
convenir à l'ensemble des territoires
d'où le fait bien sûr de responsabiliser
les citoyens et c'est notre rôle est de
donner une mission de santé publique au
maire et aux élus locaux
vous êtes chef du service de réanimation
à l'hôpital lariboisière à paris est ce
que dans votre service les signaux sont
au rouge
aujourd'hui dont les signaux ne soit pas
au rouge heureusement mais nous voyons
revenir les patients qui présentent des
formes de pneumonie grave donc
actuellement l'hôpital lariboisière nous
avons quatre patients dont deux qui sont
sous ventilation mécanique
alors c'est vrai globalement ces
patients sont moins grave que ce que
l'on a connu au cours du premier pic
épidémique néanmoins ou celles à la
montée du nombre de ces patients qui
nous inquiète en fait aujourd'hui 700
patients environ sont hospitalisés en
réanimation en france il faut savoir que
la moitié est entré en réanimation dans
les sept jours précédents
qu'est ce que vous répondez à certains
de vos collègues médecins qui estime
qu'on assiste à de la peur aujourd'hui
non je ne crois pas que en tout cas ces
personnes soient nombreuses je crois que
le temps est à la prudence est
évidemment à mettre en place de façon
plus stricte les mesures barrières
si on appliquait parfaitement les
mesures barrières on pourrait éviter
toute flambée des cas de contamination
grave et toute nécessité de mesures plus
strictes
notre tribune n'a pas pour but de de
mettre des amendes ou une réglementation
difficile à l'inversé de responsabiliser
chacun pour éviter que le gouvernement
et les autorités sanitaires en soit
amenée à imposer une limitation des
rassemblements avec deux fait
effectivement l'impossibilité que ces
réunions se fasse ainsi dans les pays
autour de nous et bien un certain nombre
de mesures ont déjà été prises en
allemagne les rassemblements sont
limités à 50 personnes
au portugal à 20 en espagne à 10 au
royaume uni à six personnes et en
belgique
il y à une même une bulle sociale
limitée à cinq personnes différentes que
vous pouvez rencontrer par semaine donc
la situation est encore beaucoup plus
strictes en france nous avons la chance
encore de pouvoir organiser des réunions
privées
mais attention celles ci doivent se
faire dans le respect des mesures
barrières et le port du masque
lorsque on ne peut pas pour des raisons
évidentes maintenir la distanciation
social ou en présence de toutes
personnes âgées ou à risque
est ce que les français auxquels vous
vous adressez dans votre tribune ne se
retrouvent pas au final un peu pris dans
une querelle de clochers dans
scientifique là je pense notamment aux
propos dans d co signataires de la
tribune le médecin jimmy mohamed qui
déclarait il ya quelques jours
ne croyez pas les charlatans en
particulier du côté de marseille qui
vous disent que tout va bien c'est faux
c'est une allusion à peine voilée au
controversé professeur en août
non le but c'est pas de polémiquer le
professeur raoul tu est un scientifique
reconnu ces opinions sont parfaitement
respectable nous les écoutons néanmoins
malheureusement la situation sanitaire
aujourd'hui y compris à marseille montre
qu' il existe un rebond de l'épidémie
certes encore un niveau beaucoup plus
bas
au moins cinq à dix fois moins de
contamination quotidienne que ce que
l'on a connu en mars avril est
clairement dix fois moins de cas en
réanimation mais les choses ont augmenté
donc évidemment notre appel a pour but
d'éviter d'en arriver à une situation
analogue est de tout faire pour éviter
le confinement généralisée merci pour
votre réaction bonhomme et gardanne chef
du service de réanimation à l'hôpital
lariboisière